Già săng tại mang California của Mỹ trong 18, đã tăng Microsoft khi xung độ dưới lên của Mỹ,
Israel và Iran làm giung chuyển thì chương năng lượng toàn cầu khiến thị dân nhiều khu vực lộ sổ tất cả chạm săng già dẻ.
Tại luật anjo-läs và của Orange, già săng đã tăng hơn mởi bay xem một cà lơm chỉ trong một ngày,
mức tăng mạnh nhất về từ năm 2020, ở thành phố Vanuys, nhiều tài sế xin hàng giải tại các chạm săng già thất như có sco,
phải chờ tới khoảng 18,000 phút mới của thế độ săng, nhiều người dân cho biết già săng tại khu vực đã lên tới bây đối mì một gà lông,
tới khoảng bối mới tám nhìn đầu một lýt, tạo thêm áp lực gà chế một người lau đạo khi chỉ phí đi lại tăng ngang nhưng tình lượng không thể đối.
Đà tăng già như liệu tại Mỹ và nhiều cuốn già dựa ra trong bối cảnh trái sự tại chúng đông,
làm giã doạn một cung năng lượng toàn cầu, hát đầu vẫn tài râu quà nhau biển hông mốt,
tuyến hàng 2 vẫn chuyển khoảng 20% lượng dầu thế giới bị an hưởng nghiêm trong khi già dầu cũng tể tăng vọt.
Thật giới phân định ngoài yếu tổ điện truyền chi, việc một số nhà may lập dầu đống cửa cùng chi phí quy định môi trường tại mang k phân nhà cũng góc phần đẩy giá săng tăng cao.
Chứ tình hình này tổ thông mý đường trong cho rằng già dầu tăng chỉ là cây giá nhỏ phải chả cho ăn link vọa bình,
đông thời dựa đoạn giá năng lượng sẽ giảm nhang khi một đezuá từ yên răng trống dất.